good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is sep11 52 object
class safe special containment
procedures scp-1155 ITAT in the site 98
animal housing wing as CP 1152 is to be
given 5 kilograms of feed meeting its
nutritional standards detailed in
document scp-1155 aced with 25
milligrams than the flexing SCP 1152 is
to be examined once every 2 months by an
on-site veterinarian following repeated
health issues access to scp-1155 to is
superficially similar to standard
members of the Procyon loader species
common raku scp-1155 kilograms despite
only being 60 centimeters from the nose
to the tip of its tail and its current
state of malnutrition SCP 1152 does not
share the genome of other members of its
species but is a near-complete match for
the human genome after logging SCP 1152
s genome in the foundation database it
was found to share ninety-nine point
eight seven percent of its genetic code
with the late agent agent was presumed
dead after being missing in action for
thirteen months his bunny is yet to be
retrieved by foundation staff along with
its human DNA as CP 1152 was proven
susceptible to pathogens normally
restricted to infecting humans scp-1155
a lifespan much longer than others of
its species having been contained for
six years a CP 1152 is missing the fifth
digit on its front left paw how a CP
1152 was injured is as of yet unknown
SCP 11:52 has exhibited intelligence on
par with an average post-pubescent human
eluding capture from staff for two weeks
after initially being found in site 98 s
personnel wing how has CP 1152 managed
to get into site 98 without being
noticed is as of yet unknown along with
how it obtained knowledge of the layout
of site 98 SC p.1154 scp-1155 beyond
what should be feasibly possible with
pause it is also capable of opening
doors and bypassing the low security
manual locks requiring the lock to its
room to be replaced with keycard access
along with the anomalous mass of
scp-1155 in 52 may possess kognito
hazardous effects in carnivorous and
omnivorous land animals any such animal
introduced to scp-1155 - as such it is
now contained in a secluded habitat
addendum scp-1155 it's escaped on 6 mm
all personnel are advised to keep their
key cards hidden on their person when
interacting with SCP 1152 the incident
report follows 10:45 a.m. SCP 1152 is
seen attempting to dig through the walls
of its habitat
10:55 a.m. agent is dispatched to
incapacitate sep11 52
11:02 am scp-1155 ciske card and escapes
containment 2:35 p.m.
scp-1155 98 supply storage and contained
once more notes as CP 1152 was found
with a stolen phone records indicate
that it's somehow dialed agent life
after presumably striking random buttons
the call lasted five minutes and
consisted entirely of scp-1155 own and
I've seen that thing it's pretty weird I
can't describe it anyway thank you all
for listening and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Muslim Mookie slump god Justin day
John reporter captain Gorge fluffy dread
my archive curator neck tie verbal Judi
Dench cheese whip depths McGee and
oblong douche boy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well
visit patreon.com forward slash live
organ thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]